I said if I gave you a breath test right
now you would blow zeros I said I didn't
have a need to drink today sir no I said
if I gave you that
test no sir I don't have anything to
drink today I didn't ask that if I gave
you a breath test you would blow zeros I
don't know what would come up on the
test but I know if you haven't had
anything to drink what should come up on
the test would it come up at zero zero
if you have it at anything right yes sir
if you have no alcohol in your system
should be zeros
hello hi you know what the speed limit
is on Southern um 4 45 40 not 70 right
I'm so sorry why are we going so
fast say that
again where are you trying to get to
just home I just
been sorry okay let me see your driver's
license and
insurance so I locked you on radar back
here at 70 and the 40 that's why I'm
stopping okay yes anything to drink
today no no alcohol at all where are you
coming from uh just from work I work at
the so
down
there okay but you're not coming from
that
way right oh no I went to the after work
and I'm going back towards work I'm
going to I'm going to go grocery
shopping okay all right any guns in the
car no sir Okay do um just do me your
favor and step out here real quick let
me check look your
eyes you have contacts in your eyes any
type of traumatic brain brain
injuries okay any type of physical
injuries okay let's put your feet
together like this he heel toe toe
perfect okay see my finger follow my
finger with just your eyes keep your
head really still for me keep your head
still
[Music]
okay let's do it this way so you so the
wind's not in your eyes no no no turn
around turn around and face
me there you
go just like
that
turn this way so you could hair your
hair can stay on your face sorry right
no stay stay right here for me I just
want want your hair to stay out of your
face
[Music]
e
almost
done we
go okay when have SE your car real quick
[Applause]
I already did HG onor I need to run it
through the rest of the field all
right
Sarah before I let you go I'm going to
do a couple more tests on you okay go
and step out
here no weapons no sir any type of
physical injuries no sir traumatic brain
injuries no sir no contacts in your eyes
either right um do you have um anything
in your mouth show
me how old are you uh 23 how much have
you had to drink today n yes you have no
sir yes no sir not a drop so if I give
you a breath test right now
zeros
zeros you
sure which test are you in the no I said
if I give you a breath test right now
you would blow zeros I said I didn't
have any need to drink today sir no I
said if I gave you that
test no sir I don't have anything to
drink today I didn't ask that if I gave
you a breath test you would blow zero
I don't know what what come up on the
test but I know if you haven't had
anything to drink what should come up on
the test would it come up at zero zero
if you have it at anything right yes sir
if you have it no alcohol in your system
should be
zeros
okay okay come on over
here you take any to take any kind of
prescription medications
you take any kind of street drugs
nothing okay the reason why I keep
asking you
this is because mainly because the eye
test I just gave you in the case you've
had something to
drink that's why I keep asking you about
that so if you've had something to drink
if you've had it shot that's cuz that's
what you smell like you
like if you got something to drink tell
me nothing okay going stand on that line
right there facing this
way put your left foot all the way on
that stay in that position put your
hands down your side side your Ps and
once you leave your hands there
throughout the entire test okay you
understand that okay these tests are
super easy I'm going to explain them in
great detail if you have any questions
just ask them all right leaving your
left foot on that line right there goad
and put your right foot in front of your
heel toe stay in that position don't
move until I tell you to start the test
do you understand that when I tell you
to start the test I want you take nine
Heel To Toe steps while looking down
your feet and Counting out loud it's
going look like this one two three I've
taken three heel the toe steps you're
going to take nine heel the toe steps
once you get on that nin step you your
Le foot planted pivot around that lead
foot exactly like I'm
doing going to want you do another nine
heel to to steps while looking down to
your feet counting out loud look like
this again one two three once again I've
taken three I want you to take nine in
both directions hold on hold
onest you don't stop okay go and get
back in that position
no left foot all the way in the
line right in front of it heel the toe
so you stay there you're at zero you're
first step's going to be one you
understand the instructions go
ahead 3 4 5 6
together again he the heel next what you
do pick a foot of your choice right or
left whatever you feel more comfortable
with when I tell you to you're going to
lift up that foot of prop to 6 in off
the ground and point your toe that the
bottom of your foot is parallel to the
ground you see how my foot is see how my
legs are fully straight extended this is
the position I want
to2 100
until I take during this test important
you keep your hand down your sides again
T you the sides of your P so this is the
position I want you you understand that
any questions no sir okay which f are we
going to pick up
I hold on hold on hold on hold on I got
to get my my timer
here go ahead okay 1001
1005 1
[Music]
201 2012 2013
2014 2015
2018 did you graduate high school yes
sir where at uh reanal SCH at Rancho
okay I want you do is count backwards
for me from the number 72 yes count
backwards and stop at the number 51 for
me okay 72 71 70 69 68 67 66 65 64 63 62
61 I'm sorry did you say stop at 70 or
stop1 60 uh 59 58 57 56
51 sorry uh 50 49 48
46 45 44 what number did I tell you to
stop at uh 51 last test is an alphabet
test you know your alphabet yes want to
see the alphabet in the correct order
going forward but I want you to start at
I and then stop a q from
me I J K L M n o p q r s g u v WX y see
sorry I think
I every test that I've given
you you've showed
impairment every test I've given you
you've showed impairment on you're going
70 and a 40 when I go to stop you did
did you see me trying to stop you back
there by golf course no I see mat
that you did okay why didn't you stop
back there um I don't know I think I
must have thought you were stopping
someone else okay and then when we pull
in here what did you do when you pulled
in that would have caught my attention
to say that's kind of weird I a break's
kind of hard I think I should have not
the braking part when you put your car
in park and you were still doing what I
was just idling no you were still
driving driving so did you hear the
click click click that that noise yeah
that's what caught my attention I was
like what what is what are you doing and
then when I come up here I smell alcohol
on you I do the eye test it confirms
that you've had alcohol and you've
showed him Pam on every single test I've
given
you and you keep telling me you haven't
anything to
drink are we going to stick with
that with that statement that you
haven't had anything to
drink
yes okay go turn room put your hands
your back you're going be placed under
arrest right now for DWI just relax your
hands totally
relax sorry I just want to ask him I on
my phone absolutely yeah
absolutely
yeah do you have anything in that
vehicle that we need to be concerned
about like drugs or guns no sir those
are the two major things no okay and
where's your cell phone at um I should
be just I think it's in my Pur on the
front seat car okay I'll grab it come
walk over here for me and do you have do
you don't have anything on your person
right now that like
um like uh n anything like that
okay uh
yes
SRA do you have any small children that
at home that depend on your care no sir
any elderly people at your home that
depend on your care okay we just have to
ask that that's
all
70 you been getting some high on high
crazy speeds 80 on good god um 46 is bad
boy
yep
and no uh I'm just taking this so just
document the purse and all that stuff
because they do not want that stuff
anymore to jail that works thank
you
step out here
please we're going to go into through
that door right over
there thank you make your
right there another right right
there yep we're going to going through
that door that's open on the left
straight
ahead
comeing over
here still nothing in your mouth correct
yes okay see
[Applause]
sh
see what about tell you is very
important to listen to
me first of all you're under arrest for
DWI imply consent act requires you to
submit to a breath test to determine the
alcohol content of your blood after you
take our test you have the right to
choose an additional independent test if
you choose to take this additional
independent test test you have the right
to a reasonable opportunity to arrange
for a physician a licensed nurse labtech
or technologist who is employed by a
hospital or a physician of your own
choice to perform an additional chemical
test the cost of this additional test
will be paid for by the law enforcement
agency do you agree to take our test our
test is going to be the breath test I
agree
done one of these tests
before your mouthpiece when I tell you
to You'll stand up and just blow into
that mouth piece nice tight blow into
the machine until I take you stop you'll
have to blow for about four or 5 Seconds
you'll have to do the test twice and
then it'll show where you're
at
spe
okay
go
that really deep breath and then blow
until I take you a stop deep breath in
and then blow
hard keep going keep going you stop you
got to keep that tone going deep breath
and
then keep going keep going keep going
keep going don't stop keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
good okay
see
[Music]
for
set
up exact same thing deep breath blow
until I tell you
stop keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going good okay
see Sarah do you know what the legal
liit
is at
[Music]
that's you'll be here for
about 45 minutes and then I'll take you
down to the county jail they will
probably book you in there and probably
rele
here somebody that can pick you
up yeah
I okay come on out here
please let me see if they clean this
one I did not
so come on over
here you have a belt on yes okay kick
off your tennis shoes right
here over
here you'll be in here for about 45
minutes and then I'll Take You Down
okay and you have enough battery I just
ask you that cuz if you don't I can
charge it for you okay thank you good
okay sure go sip right here
please go and put your shoes on you can
put your phone in your
pocket put your hands like this your
first I'm going to put them in here CU I
know it's a lot easier to get in my car
like this when I get you done in the
jail I'll have to put in the
back come
on
swing this
around what' you say you work at UH
Smiths Smiths yes oh of 528 metal AR
yeah how long you been there uh 5 years
I heard it's a pretty good store to work
for yeah that's what I've heard no I
like working I like what do you do um I
working grocery now some sun store I
used to work in the bakery like doing
cakes and stuff
okay
no right there
just hello hello know